programming throwdown episode 56 robotics take it away jason hey everybody so uh I have a new microphone super excited about that You sound amazing Thank you There was a Reddit thread It said what programming podcast do you like on Learn Programming I think subreddit and a bunch of people said Programming Throwdown
Programming Throwdown 第56期，机器人技术，Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，我换了个新麦克风，对此我超级兴奋。你听起来棒极了。谢谢。Reddit上有一个帖子，在Learn Programming这个子版块里有人问大家喜欢哪个编程播客，很多人都提到了Programming Throwdown。
which is awesome, thank you guys so much and of course you know, we had to look at all the comments. And like any like anyone, your brain goes like straight to the negative comments and you kind of read those. And a bunch of people said, oh, Patrick sounds pretty good. But Jason sounds like he got his microphone in a garage sale, which I did. So I actually did literally had my microphone from a thrift shop. So I bought a new microphone. I followed Patrick's advice and got the same microphone as he did.
这太棒了，非常感谢大家。当然，我们肯定会看所有的评论。就像任何人一样，你的大脑会直接关注负面评论，然后你会去读那些。很多人说，哦，Patrick听起来不错，但Jason听起来像是从车库旧货甩卖买的麦克风，我确实是这么做的。我真的是从旧货店买的麦克风。所以我买了一个新麦克风，我听从了Patrick的建议，买了和他一样的麦克风。
And I'm really excited, really happy to have some new equipment. I even got a pop filter. So look out. Oh, wait. Now you've surpassed me. Oh, I thought you had a pop filter. No. Okay.
我真的很兴奋，很高兴能有新设备。我甚至买了一个防喷罩。所以，小心了。哦，等等。现在你超过我了。哦，我以为你有防喷罩。没有。好吧。
Look out. Now it's like, what's that called? Yeah, keep up with the Joneses. The next thing we need to do is get those anechoic panels that we wrap around when we record so we don't get echoes and like room noise. And then we'll be professionals. Yeah, yeah, totally. That's the next step.
小心了。现在这叫什么来着？对，跟上潮流。我们接下来要做的是弄那些我们在录音时围在周围的消音板，这样我们就不会有回声和房间噪音了。然后我们就是专业人士了。是的，完全正确。这是下一步。
Is that those like corrugated gray foam things? They have like little pyramids on them? Yeah, right, right. Yeah. I think they're called anechoic. Hey, sounds good to me. Sounds awesome. So on to news.
是那种波纹状的灰色泡沫东西吗？上面有小金字塔的那种？对，没错。是的，我想它们叫消音板。嘿，听起来不错。听起来很棒。那么，进入新闻环节。
So yeah, this is pretty cool. I would have put it as my tool of the show, but I haven't used it yet. It's still also a bit early, but I think it's a great idea. It's called MARP, Markdown Precision Writer. And the idea is it's this desktop app you download, and then you start writing Markdown, and it converts your Markdown into a PowerPoint presentation. And the reason why that is really cool is the PowerPoint presentation can be packaged as like a website. And in the markdown, you can have HTML. So in other words, like you could have a presentation where in the presentation are some charts that are dynamically generated.
是的，这很酷。我本来想把它作为我的本期工具，但我还没用过。现在说还早了点，但我认为这是一个好主意。它叫MARP，Markdown Precision Writer。它的想法是，这是一个你下载的桌面应用程序，然后你开始写Markdown，它会将你的Markdown转换为PowerPoint演示文稿。之所以这很酷，是因为PowerPoint演示文稿可以像网站一样打包。在Markdown中，你可以使用HTML。换句话说，你可以有一个演示文稿，其中包含一些动态生成的图表。
Like the presentation could make a web request to, you know, your server and pull back some charts. I mean, in a way that's kind of bad because the data could change and not represent what you wanted. But I mean, that's maybe not the best example, but you could have a link to Google Maps and you actually have the Google Maps, you know, iframe and it's interactive. And so it's pretty cool. You know, I'm gonna try it out. I've always been looking for a better, you know, presentation software. It's kind of more lightweight and things like that. I'm that guy who just has all my presentations are just white background black text. So yeah, I'm gonna try this out and if it's good I might
比如演示文稿可以向你的服务器发出网络请求，并拉取一些图表。我的意思是，从某种程度上说这有点糟糕，因为数据可能会改变，不能代表你想要展示的内容。但我的意思是，这可能不是最好的例子，但你可以有一个指向谷歌地图的链接，你实际上拥有谷歌地图的iframe，而且它是交互式的。所以这很酷。你知道，我要试一试。我一直在寻找更好的演示软件。它更轻量级之类的。我就是那种所有演示文稿都只有白色背景和黑色文字的人。所以是的，我要试试这个，如果它好用的话，我可能会
double dip and make it my tool of the show in the future. That's cheating. That's what we do. We cheat. Also, I would hope there's a compiling step or whatever where it generates the PowerPoint and then it kind of freezes your data at that step. No? Oh, well, I think, I mean, you could definitely do that.
再次使用它，并在未来把它作为我的本期工具。那是作弊。这就是我们所做的。我们作弊。另外，我希望有一个编译步骤，生成PowerPoint，然后在那个步骤冻结你的数据。没有吗？哦，好吧，我想，我的意思是，你绝对可以那样做。
What you would do in that case is, like, you would have, like, you would probably just take a screenshot of your data. You know what I mean? Or something like that. But it can generate this kind of website or it can export to PDF, which is about as good as you can get. I mean, exporting to, like, PowerPoint would be really hard. So I don't expect that's going to happen anytime soon. But a PDF is pretty good. Okay.
在这种情况下，你会怎么做，比如，你可能会截取你的数据截图。你知道我的意思吗？或者类似的东西。但它可以生成这种网站，或者它可以导出为PDF，这已经足够好了。我的意思是，导出为PowerPoint会非常困难。所以我预计短期内不会发生这种情况。但PDF已经很不错了。好的。
Well, go try it out and report back. That's right. The next story I have was making its rounds. The Apollo guidance computer source code was posted to GitHub. Apparently, this has actually been out in the public several times before. I've never seen it before but this is some of the code written to control um the apollo mission for the guidance system and it was written in a custom assembly that they made but the most interesting things i guess are noticed the comments in the code that people wrote and
好吧，去试试看并回来汇报。没错。我有的下一个故事正在流传。阿波罗制导计算机的源代码被发布到了GitHub上。显然，这在过去已经多次公开过。我以前从未见过它，但这是编写来控制阿波罗任务制导系统的一些代码，它是用他们制作的自定义汇编语言编写的，但我猜最有趣的是注意到代码中人们写的注释，以及
probably assumed would not be written or at least would not be written what is that uh 50 years later yeah 51 years later so things like temporary I hope I hope I hope like I hope that someone deletes this code one day yeah no and there's just you know other kind of silly comments and quotes. And I guess things at the time maybe even weren't that significant. But later, reading back, it's kind of interesting to see what people chose. I guess if you were an author, people would look at this and say, what did they mean here? This is an allegory for what? But it was probably the person just being goofy when they wrote it.
可能认为不会被写下来，或者至少不会在50年后被写下来。是的，51年后。所以像“临时”这样的东西，我希望我希望我希望有人有一天能删除这段代码。是的，还有其他一些愚蠢的评论和引语。我想当时的事情可能甚至没那么重要。但后来回读时，看看人们选择了什么很有趣。我想如果你是一位作者，人们会看着这个说，他们在这里是什么意思？这是什么的寓言？但这可能只是写它的人在搞怪。
Yeah, totally. it's interesting i'm sorry what is the weirdest piece of code you've ever seen or like funniest or i mean we've both worked at big companies which have giant code bases and sometimes you're just diving through the code you see something completely bizarre i mean i think the only one and i i've probably talked about it before, is the first time I came across it, some bit of code that had a big comment and said, voodoo black magic starts here. Do not alter unless you want everything to crash. That's awesome. But other than that, I haven't know why, but return one here. And the next line was return zero.
是的，完全正确。这很有趣，抱歉，你见过最奇怪的代码是什么，或者最有趣的，我的意思是，我们都在大公司工作过，那里有庞大的代码库，有时你只是在代码中潜水，你会看到一些完全离奇的东西。我的意思是，我想唯一的一个，我可能以前谈到过，是我第一次遇到它时，一段代码有一个大注释，写着“巫毒黑魔法从这里开始。除非你想让一切崩溃，否则不要修改。”这太棒了。但除此之外，我不知道为什么，但这里返回1。下一行是返回0。
What? Yeah. I fussed at someone the other day. I read a comment. No, no, it was like a log statement. And I was like, oh, this is not correct. You know, your code's not doing the right thing. But in my mind, I like had saw the And I was like, oh, this is not correct. Your code's not doing the right thing. But in my mind, I saw the log comment was wrong
什么？是的。前几天我责备了某人。我读了一条评论。不，不，那就像一条日志语句。我说，哦，这不正确。你知道，你的代码没有做正确的事情。但在我的脑海里，我看到了……我说，哦，这不正确。你的代码没有做正确的事情。但在我的脑海里，我看到了日志注释是错的
and I never bothered to actually read what the code was doing. I just assumed the code was wrong as well. But actually the code was correct and they just like copy and paste, errored the log comment. And I was like, oops, should have read the code. But it was fair, I guess, from my standpoint
我从来没有费心去读代码在做什么。我只是假设代码也是错的。但实际上代码是正确的，他们只是复制粘贴时弄错了日志注释。我说，哎呀，应该读一下代码。但我想从我的角度来看，这是公平的
that if you had the like why would i keep reading if the comments aren't right yeah actually there's something that uh someone said to me um that's really profound is is uh unless you're working on a project by yourself um any code you write will be witnessed by at least twice as many people. In other words, you're going to read it again one day, and someone else was going to read it again one day, at least. And so write code as if you expect it to be read many times. And I thought that was kind of like a profound statement. A lot of people still don't follow that, though.
如果你有……为什么如果注释不正确我还要继续读呢？是的，实际上有人对我说了些非常深刻的话，就是……除非你是在独自做一个项目，否则你写的任何代码都会被至少两倍多的人看到。换句话说，有一天你会再读一遍，有一天别人也会再读一遍，至少。所以写代码时要像你期望它被多次阅读一样。我觉得这是一个深刻的陈述。不过很多人仍然不遵循这一点。
Yeah, no, I mean, we're all guilty of it at different times so my news article is the microsoft r client um i haven't tried this it looks pretty cool um basically uh it's a it's an r front end and uh it works with big data so um there's uh various kind of like r operators that you can run on the data to do transformations, do dot product, do things like that. But if you use this R library, let me see if I can find the name of the library. But yeah, if you use this one library, then it'll actually run on the cloud. So you could do a dot product of a billion-sized vector with another billion-sized vector, and it'll just distribute everything.
是的，不，我的意思是，我们在不同的时候都有罪。所以我的新闻文章是微软的R客户端，我还没试过，看起来很酷。基本上，它是一个R前端，它适用于大数据。所以，有一些你可以对数据运行的各种R操作符来进行转换、点积、做类似的事情。但如果你使用这个R库，让我看看能不能找到这个库的名字。但是的，如果你使用这个库，那么它实际上会在云端运行。所以你可以对一个十亿大小的向量和另一个十亿大小的向量进行点积，它会分发一切。
Revo ScaleR? That's what it is, yep. The ScaleR technology and proprietary functions. So the deal is the R client is open source. The base R distribution client is open source. The base, like, you know, R distribution is obviously open source. But then if you call any of these scalar functions that are owned by Microsoft, those are closed source. So if there's a bug in one of those, you know, you have to go chase down someone at Microsoft. But, yeah yeah it seems
Revo ScaleR？就是那个，没错。ScaleR技术和专有函数。所以问题是R客户端是开源的。基础R发行版客户端是开源的。基础，比如，R发行版显然是开源的。但如果你调用任何这些由微软拥有的ScaleR函数，那些是闭源的。所以如果其中一个有bug，你知道，你必须去追查微软的某个人。但，是的，是的，它看起来
pretty cool i mean there's a lot of people who use r a lot of statisticians and uh um the idea that you know they could just kind of take what they've done and move it over to to big data is kind of a cool idea i mean obviously you can't do the same things as you can do like you don't have the full power that you do in r because um you don't have the same kind of data locality. So if you're going to break the data up into chunks, each chunk can only see the data that it's assigned to, that is assigned to it. So you can't do everything, but you can do a lot of things. And yeah, I thought this was pretty cool. I'm definitely going to be checking it out this week.
很酷。我的意思是，有很多使用R的人，很多统计学家，而且……他们可以把他们所做的东西转移到大数据上的想法是一个很酷的想法。我的意思是，显然你不能做你在R中能做的所有事情，因为你没有同样的数据局部性。所以如果你要把数据分成块，每一块只能看到分配给它的数据。所以你不能做所有事情，但你可以做很多事情。是的，我觉得这很酷。我这周肯定会去看看。
Pokemon Go. do a lot of things and uh yeah i thought this was pretty cool i'm definitely going to be checking it out this week pokemon go oh my gosh i'm sorry i just don't even like so i'll tell you my experience with it i uh i downloaded it um i fought the the you know test enemy i think i picked squirtle and i fought squirtle i defeated him and so i have you know the like very first introductory pokemon um and that's it so i'm totally lacking um i definitely want to get into it but uh i haven't done it yet but it is insanely popular so you got a little bit further right no oh no so i kept telling myself i'm gonna download it and try it out because i have fond memories of pokemon when i when the original red and blue came out and i was i guess i don't remember how old i must have been at the time but a little on the older side so as like a game boy so you're probably like nine or something but as like a first rpg it was something that was very good for me, I guess.
Pokemon Go。做很多事情，是的，我觉得这很酷，我这周肯定会去看看。Pokemon Go，天哪，抱歉，我甚至不喜欢……所以我告诉你我的经历。我下载了它，我与测试敌人战斗，我想我选了杰尼龟，我与杰尼龟战斗，我打败了他，所以我有了第一个入门宝可梦，就是这样。所以我完全缺乏……我绝对想参与其中，但我还没做。但它非常受欢迎。所以你走得远一点了，对吧？不，哦，不。所以我一直告诉自己我要下载它并试一试，因为我对宝可梦有美好的回忆，当最初的红蓝版本出来时，我猜我不记得当时我多大了，但稍微大一点。所以像Game Boy，你可能九岁左右，但作为第一个RPG，它对我来说非常好，我想。
Japanese RPGs weren't, or at least not among people I knew, weren't a big deal at that time. And so I really enjoyed it. But then it wasn't really a cultural thing at that point. It wasn't until later that the cartoon show and stuff started to come out but by that time it was i was a little older and it was like more something my younger brother and his friends were into so then i still play i wanted to still play the game but uh you know i couldn't be into it and so now that i'm an adult right like you know whatever but but as a
日本RPG在当时并不是，或者至少在我认识的人中，不是什么大不了的事情。所以我真的很喜欢它。但那时它并不是一种文化现象。直到后来卡通片之类的东西开始出现，但那时我已经大了一点，这更像是我的弟弟和他的朋友们感兴趣的东西。所以我仍然玩，我想继续玩这个游戏，但你知道，我无法沉迷其中。所以现在我是一个成年人了，对吧，不管怎样，但作为一个
kid i guess i made the decision not to be quote unquote into it but i still do remember all the pokemon and i was always better at the game than my brother because i was older uh nice but no i keep telling myself i was gonna download it but then i got freaked out because i read some article that was saying that it uses your google login and it the permissions it grants actually gives it access to like everything in your google account not just like read email or read your email contacts or your email address but like And the permissions it grants actually gives it access to like everything in your Google account. Not just like read email or read your email contacts or your email address, but like actually read all of your email. And they're saying it's most likely that they're not using it.
孩子，我想我决定不“沉迷”于它，但我仍然记得所有的宝可梦，而且我总是比我弟弟玩得好，因为我年纪大。不错，但不，我一直告诉自己我要下载它，但我被吓坏了，因为我读到一篇文章说它使用你的谷歌登录，它授予的权限实际上让它能够访问你谷歌账户中的所有内容，不仅仅是读取电子邮件或读取你的电子邮件联系人或你的电子邮件地址，而是像……它授予的权限实际上让它能够访问你谷歌账户中的所有内容。不仅仅是读取电子邮件或读取你的电子邮件联系人或你的电子邮件地址，而是像实际上读取你所有的电子邮件。他们说最有可能的是他们没有使用它。
But, you know, it could be a problem. Yeah, they actually just pushed, they posted a news story saying that they fixed that. Okay, so I will download it. Yeah, I guess there's an issue where, like, once you ask for something, you can't ask for less. Because that's kind of, like, giving the illusion that you weren't collecting it when you were. But given that this is already more popular than Twitter, I think, like, Google made an exception. And, like, Google like google engineers like worked something out with them um but yeah that's so it's kind of gets to the article the article um is just
但是，你知道，这可能是一个问题。是的，他们刚刚发布了一条新闻，说他们修复了那个问题。好的，那我会下载它。是的，我想有一个问题是，一旦你要求某样东西，你就不能要求更少。因为这就像给人一种错觉，即你在收集它时并没有收集它。但考虑到这已经比Twitter更受欢迎了，我想，谷歌做了一个例外。而且，谷歌工程师和他们一起解决了一些问题，但是的，这有点涉及到这篇文章，这篇文章……只是
i just cannot believe how popular and it only came out what a week ago i think yeah and it's just insanely popular like it's already more popular on twitter uh nintendo stock went up seven billion dollars or something it's just insane um and uh the article specifically talks about the augmented reality portion of it um so you didn't get to fight the first monster right no okay so so or i guess the first pokemon but it it does this thing where it... I don't even know how it works because they don't have 3D vision or anything. It must be based on passive movement.
我简直不敢相信它有多受欢迎，它才出来，我想才一周吧？是的，它简直太受欢迎了，它在Twitter上已经更受欢迎了，任天堂的股票上涨了70亿美元左右，这简直太疯狂了。而且，这篇文章专门讨论了它的增强现实部分。所以你没能打败第一个怪物，对吧？不，好的。所以或者我猜是第一个宝可梦，但它确实做了这件事，它……我甚至不知道它是怎么工作的，因为他们没有任何3D视觉之类的东西。它一定是基于被动运动。
They try to do some kind of stereo vision thing. Isn't that structure from motion? Yeah, yeah, that's right. So it figures out... Again, in our case, we were at an ice cream shop and uh my wife and i were trying it out and um like squirtle like was just sitting on one of the benches in the ice cream shop and actually recognized like in 3d sort of what that represented and he was just chilling there and we just flicked a pokemon ball on them and caught them and it's just amazing
他们试图做某种立体视觉的东西。那不是运动结构吗？是的，没错。所以它弄清楚了……同样，在我们的例子中，我们在一家冰淇淋店，我和我妻子正在试用它，杰尼龟就像坐在冰淇淋店的长椅上，实际上识别出了它在3D中代表什么，它就在那里闲逛，我们只是向它扔了一个宝可梦球并抓住了它，这太神奇了。
so yeah i definitely uh so so so the article talks about how amazing hug vintage reality is and how it's the future and everything i believe it i think it's i think it's interesting that from what i understand it's pretty similar technology wise to ingress the niantic Labs game but obviously this has far and away eclipsed anything that Ingress ever was as far as the amount of people the cultural awareness of it yeah it started as
所以是的，我绝对……所以这篇文章谈到了增强现实是多么神奇，它是未来等等。我相信它，我认为有趣的是，据我所知，在技术上它与Ingress，那个Niantic Labs的游戏非常相似，但显然这在人数和文化意识方面已经远远超过了Ingress曾经的一切。是的，它始于
an April Fool's joke in Google Maps the article talks about this and I don't even remember exactly what the April Fool's... I mean, I remember seeing it at the time. There's some April Fool's joke that juxtaposed maps with Pokemon. I don't know if it replaced all the buildings or gyms.
谷歌地图上的一个愚人节玩笑，文章谈到了这一点，我甚至不记得那个愚人节玩笑到底是什么……我的意思是，我记得当时看到了它。有一个愚人节玩笑将地图与宝可梦并置。我不知道它是否取代了所有的建筑物或道馆。
I don't know. But it was insanely popular. And then they realized that there's this huge you know a pokemon fan base that they could tap into i will be downloading it i will be playing it i will probably show my kids how awesome it is and they will think i'm an amazing person for being able to capture pokemon if we if you don't see us if we don't have an episode next month you'll know why we're running around trying to catch pokemon i saw articles devoted to selecting an external battery for your iphone because it drains so much battery oh no i guess the gps i have no idea but it was just funny that everyone's trying to cash
我不知道。但它非常受欢迎。然后他们意识到有一个巨大的宝可梦粉丝群可以利用。我会下载它，我会玩它，我可能会向我的孩子们展示它有多棒，他们会认为我是一个了不起的人，因为我能捕捉宝可梦。如果我们下个月没有节目，你就知道为什么了，我们在到处跑试图捕捉宝可梦。我看到文章专门讨论为你的iPhone选择外接电池，因为它太耗电了。哦，不，我猜是GPS，我不知道，但每个人都试图通过在标题中加入Pokemon Go来点击诱饵，这很有趣。这太棒了。是的，所以下一集我们肯定会更多地讨论它，因为到那时我们希望已经玩过了。本期图书，本期图书，我的本期图书是2016年美国拼图锦标赛，刚刚发生。如果你点击节目笔记中的这个网址，你可以免费下载这些拼图。比赛已经结束了，所以你今年不能参赛了，但我确实参加了2006年到2010年的比赛，我并不是特别擅长，我想有一年我进入了前100名，但我没能去参加世界锦标赛之类的疯狂比赛。
in on the you know click baiting by putting pokemon go in your headline that's awesome um yeah so yeah next episode we will definitely we'll definitely talk about it more as we would have hopefully played it by then book of the show book this show my book of the show is the u.s puzzle championship 2016 which just happened um you can go to this url if you uh if you click on the show notes and you can download the puzzles uh for free uh the the contest is over so you can't you can't uh uh you can't compete this year but uh um i did compete uh 2006 through 2010 and i wasn't like particularly you know that good i think it was in like top 100 one year but like I didn't get to go to the world championship or anything crazy like that
但它超级有趣，你不必是一个程序员，尽管你实际上可以使用计算机在实际比赛中作弊。他们给你两个半小时。所以你必须手工解决这些逻辑谜题。因为，我的意思是，我想你可以作弊。你可以写一堆脚手架代码，这样你就可以快速生成一个程序。但据我所知，没有人真的这样做。如果你这样做并去了世界锦标赛，他们不允许你使用计算机。所以那会很奇怪，但你可以使用计算机来解决谜题，比如暴力破解它之类的，这是一种有趣的练习。你也可以自己解决它。
but it's super fun you don't have to be a programmer although you can actually use the computer to kind of cheat in the actual contest they give you two and a half hours. And so you kind of have to sort of solve these logic puzzles by hand. Because, I mean, I guess you could cheat. You could write a bunch of scaffolding code in such a way where you could quickly churn out a program. But as far as I know, nobody actually does that. And if you did that and it went to the World Championship, they don't let you use a computer. So that would be kind of weird but uh but you can actually use a computer to solve the puzzles like brute force it or whatever it's kind of a fun exercise um you can also solve it yourself
通过使用各种方法，比如回归、还原论方法之类的，以及逻辑。那么一个例子问题是什么，或者他们问的问题是什么样的？像数独谜题吗？不，它……好吧，是的，有点像。所以你可以把数独看作是一个逻辑谜题。所以这只是一个伞形术语，数独可能是其中的一个问题，对吧？当然。所以它们基本上是那个主题的变体。所以有一些是你有一堆不同的重量，你有一堆不同的秤，你必须让所有的秤平衡，但要使用所有的重量，例如。它们都是变体。
by using various kinds like regression uh reductionist methods and things like that and logic so what is an example question or what are the kinds of questions that they ask like sudoku puzzles like uh no it's well yeah kind of so so you could think of it as you could think of sudoku as like a logic puzzle um and so this is just sort of like an umbrella of which sudoku you know could be one of the questions right sure um so they're basically variants on that theme so there's there's some where uh you have a bunch of different weights and you have a bunch of different scales and you have to make all the scales balance uh but use all the weights for example right they're all they're all variations
属于NP难问题，但它们不像“找到一个算法然后运行它”，它只是“解决一个谜题实例”。完全正确。所以他们给你一套规则和一个谜题实例，然后你应该解决那个谜题实例。是的，完全正确。但它们不是你以前见过的谜题，对吧？没错。但关于它的事情是，你不能暴力破解它，所以你通常必须找到一些技巧，从根本上减少搜索空间。如果你有这些技巧，那么你可以很快写出程序。但如果你有技巧，你就不需要程序，除非你必须解决一千个这样的问题。所以这真的是
of mp hard problems but but they're not like find an algorithm and then run it it's just like solve an instance of the puzzle exactly okay so they give you some rule set in an instance of a puzzle and then you're supposed to solve that instance of the puzzle yeah exactly okay but they're not um they're not puzzles you would have seen before right that's right um but yeah it's it's uh the thing about it is like you can't brute force it so you often have to find like some tricks that like radically reduce the search space and uh and so if you have those tricks then you could write the program pretty quickly but if you have the trick you don't need the program um unless you have to solve like a thousand of these right um so that's really what it's all
关于尝试理解模式，并尝试理解具体什么事情不能发生，这样你就不必考虑那些事情了。一旦你缩小了范围，你就尝试所有的可能性。这很有趣，我的意思是，我做了很长时间。我希望我能说我很擅长它。我绝对比普通人好，但我远没有达到那些世界冠军的水平，他们简直太疯狂了。那是一个谦虚的疯狂，以一种好的方式。但是的，这是真的。但无论如何，这真的很有趣，你们一定要试一试。他们也有解决方案，所以你可以确保你在正确的轨道上。
about is like trying to understand the patterns and try to understand like specifically like what things cannot happen so that you don't have to think about those things and then once you've got it narrowed down then you just try all the possibilities it's a lot of fun i mean i did it for a long time uh i wish i could say i was good at it um i'm definitely better than like an average person but i'm not anywhere near as good as like these like world champions who are just crazy um that was a humble crazy in a good way but but uh uh yes yeah but yeah it's true but anyway so so this is really fun you guys should definitely try it out um they uh they also have solutions um so you can make sure you're on the right track and things like that
所以一定要看看。听起来像家庭作业。是的，我正在试图弄清楚，我想它有趣的原因是它就像数独，如果你喜欢数独。
so definitely check it out sounds like homework yeah that's I'm trying to figure out like I think the reason why it's fun is it's like Sudoku if you like Sudoku
而且你知道，你厌倦了做同样的谜题只是数字不同，那么这会让你大吃一惊。但我感觉数独的很多吸引力在于弄清楚那些技巧，然后一遍又一遍地应用它们。对我来说，你知道，它最终变得无聊了。但你可以有你的个人模式或技巧，或者你甚至可能知道技巧，但选择不使用它们，只是因为你喜欢更随意地做。我觉得这会很困难。
and you know you're tired of doing kind of the same puzzle just with different numbers then this you this will blow your mind but i feel like a lot of the appeal of sudoku sudoku i don't know how to say it is figuring out those tricks and then getting to apply them over and over and for me you know it eventually becomes boring um but you can kind of have your personal pattern or tricks, or you may even know tricks, but choose not to use them just because you like doing it more casually. I feel like it would be difficult.
我会试一试看看。我觉得为一个单一的问题和答案学习一套规则对我来说没那么有趣。是的，我想，我觉得有两种满足感，我不知道这是否涉及到心理学，但有些人从新奇中获得满足感。就像，哦，我看到了我以前没见过的东西，就像，哦，我去了马丘比丘，我很高兴，因为我做到了。然后有些人是
I'll try it out and see. I feel like learning a rule set for a single question and answer is less interesting to me. Yeah, I think it's, I feel like there's two types of kind of satisfaction and i don't this is getting to like psychology or whatever but there's there's people who like get satisfaction from novelty it's like oh i saw this thing i didn't see before like oh i went to manchu pichu and i'm just happy because i did it and then there's people who are like
我弹这首吉他曲比上次更准确，这让我很高兴。所以每周做数独的人属于第二类，而这属于第一类。所以这是一种不同的满足感。是的，我想我更多地……好吧，我刚才说了第二类，但我认为我更多是第一类。我通常喜欢在某件事的最初阶段找到乐趣，所以我猜这与我的陈述相矛盾。是的，好吧，我应该试试这个，我会回来汇报。好的，所以你要告诉我们关于MARP的事，我会告诉我们关于这个的事。没错，我们有家庭作业。有人会提醒我们的。我的本期图书是《黑剑之子》，这是他写的另一个系列，上次也是。所以无论如何，我显然和这位作者有什么联系。
i played this guitar song like more accurately than I did last time and that makes me happy right and so the people who do sudoku every week are in category two and this is like category one so it's like a different kind of satisfaction yeah I think I'm more in well I just said category two but I think I'm more category one i typically do like find enjoyment for the first little bit of something so i guess that contradicts my statement yeah well i should try this i'll report back all right so you're gonna tell us about mark and i'm gonna tell us about this that's right we homework. Someone will remind us. My book of the show is Son of the Black Sword, which is a different series that he writes that last time. So anyways, I'm obviously having some sort of thing with this author.
我听了这本书。他根本没有赞助这个播客。不，我开玩笑的。是的，如果你想联系我们并给我们钱。所以我是在通勤时听《黑剑之子》的。我真的很喜欢它。这是一本奇幻书。有时传统的奇幻书第一本会有点奇怪，因为它们在做很多世界构建。
And I listened to this book. He's not sponsoring the podcast at all. No, I'm just kidding. Yes, if you would like to contact us and send us money. So I listened to Sun of the Black Sword on my commute. I really enjoyed it. It's a fantasy book. And sometimes traditional fantasy books get a little bit weird the first one because they're kind of doing a lot of world building.
但我感觉这本书在世界构建和拥有一个从头到尾都有进展的有趣故事之间取得了很好的平衡。显然，它没有把所有事情都交代清楚，因为它是一个系列，而且它实际上没有像许多书那样有一个明确的结局，但它确实有一个清晰的轨迹。我觉得它本身你可以读这个故事……哦，不，我想说你可以读这个故事并对它所处的位置感到满意，而不必读下一本。但它有点……我不想剧透任何东西，但那并不完全正确。所以无论如何，如果你对奇幻感兴趣，就去看看吧。我觉得里面的概念对我来说相当原创。有时我说，哦，这本奇幻书有这个想法，我觉得
But I felt this book struck a really good balance of world building and also having an interesting story that had some progression from start to end. Obviously, it didn't tie everything up because it's a series uh and it actually didn't have as much of an end as many books do but it did have a you know a clear trajectory and i felt like there was on its own you could just read this story oh no i'm trying to say you could read the story and be happy with where it is and not have to read the next one but it it kind of i don't want to spoil anything but that's not completely true so anyways check it out if you're interested in fantasy um the concepts i felt in it were pretty original to me sometimes i say that like oh this fantasy book had this idea that i thought
真的很酷，我以前从来没那样想过。然后有人告诉我，哦，不，那实际上来自某本旧书。而这位作者只是在重炒它。所以我不会说这是原创的，但对我来说，这本书里的一些想法是新颖的，我觉得它们很有趣。所以这就是Larry Correa的《黑剑之子》。
was really cool i was i never thought about it that way before. And someone tells me, oh no, that's actually from some older book. And this author just kind of is rehashing it. So I won't say that this is original, but to me, some of the ideas that were in this book were kind of novel and I found them interesting. So that's Son of the Black Sword by Larry Correa.
我们会在节目笔记中提供链接。或者我们由Audible赞助。如果你去audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以获得Audible的一个月免费订阅，这意味着你可以下载任何书。比如《黑剑之子》，或者上面有很多很多书。我们有一大堆我们推荐的书，或者我猜大部分是我推荐的。
And we'll have the link in the show notes. Or we are sponsored by Audible. And if you go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown, you can get a free one-month subscription to Audible, which means you can download any books you could download. Center of the Black Sword or there's many, many books on there. We've a whole host of books that we've recommended, or I guess mostly I've recommended.
Jason的书不在Audible美国区，尽管我确实……我正在读《红衫》，哦，是的，关于星际迷航的那本。是的，那是一本很棒的书。哦，你在享受它，很好。是的，它非常有趣。很好。是的，我很高兴你在写评论时没有剧透，因为……现在不要剧透。是的，我知道，但我完全没预料到发生了什么，而且它真的很棒。我的意思是，我现在真的很沉迷其中。好的，是的，做这些评论真的很难，因为我觉得书的很大一部分应该是惊喜。我实际上尽量少读关于书的内容，只要足够让我感兴趣就行。
Jason's book isn't on Audible, U.S. although i did uh i am halfway through red shirt oh yes about the star trek thing yeah that that is an awesome book oh you're enjoying it good yeah it's very fun good yep um yeah it's actually the i'm glad you didn't spoil it when you gave your review because um don't spoil it now yeah yeah i know but i was totally not expecting um you know what happened and uh it was it was really you know really awesome i mean it's like it i'm really into it now okay yeah it's really hard to do these because i feel a lot of a book should be a surprise and i actually tried to read as little as possible about the books just enough to kind
在听或读它们之前。所以我总是觉得给评论很尴尬，因为我不想说太多。比如我没有说任何关于《黑剑之子》的具体内容，你除了知道可能有一把黑剑和某个儿子之外，不知道它讲的是什么。但是的，我只是不想把任何惊喜泄露出去。因为那是读书的很大一部分乐趣。是的，完全正确。所以我们也在Patreon上。所以你可以去patreon.com/programmingthrowdown，我们也会在节目笔记中提供链接。
of know i'd be interested in before listening or reading them uh and so i so i always feel awkward giving the review because i don't want to say too much like i didn't say anything specific about son of the black sword you have no idea what it's about other than there's probably a black sword and somebody who's a son um but yeah i just don't want to give any of the surprise away. Cause that's like a lot of the awesomeness of reading a book. Yeah, totally. So we're also, um, on Patreon. Um, so you can go to patreon.com slash programming throw down, and we'll have a link to that in the show notes as well.
而且，如果你们有兴趣每集捐款，我们也会在Patreon上发布MP3。他们有相当高的带宽连接等等。所以，是的，Patreon和Audible。去看看吧。是的。感谢所有做这两件事的人。我们真的很感激。
Um, and, uh, and that's where, uh, you know, if you, uh, feel inclined to like give a donation each episode, uh, we also post, um, we also post MP3s on Patreon. They have a pretty high bandwidth connection and all of that. So, yeah, Patreon and Audible. Check it out. Yeah. And thank you to all of you who have been doing both of those things. We really appreciate it.
是的，绝对。是时候进行本期工具环节了。我的本期工具，考虑到机器人技术的主题，这有点牵强，但这是一个好主意。我的本期工具是Evoluent垂直鼠标。我实际上自从你我见面以来，工作时就一直用这种鼠标。我家里没有，因为这对于游戏来说毫无用处。但如果你坐在电脑前以编程为生，或者只是长时间工作，这个鼠标很棒。
Yeah, absolutely. Time for tool of the show. My tool of the show, given the whole theme of sort of robotics and kind of more this is a little bit of a stretch but it was a good idea yeah my tool to show is uh my i'm not gonna say this right evoluent evoluent vertical mouse and so i've had actually this um since actually since since you and i met i've had one of these mice for work. I don't have one at home because this would be useless for gaming. But if you sit at a computer doing programming for a living or just for a lot of hours, this mouse is awesome.
它是一个垂直鼠标，所以很难描述。不，我不认为它是。如果你把手伸直，通常你用手掌对着桌面握住鼠标，相反，你用手掌对着键盘握住它，如果你是右手或左手，手掌对着键盘，然后你用拇指做一个捏的动作。是的，就像想象你要和某人握手。哦，在那儿。这有点像你的手整天看起来或感觉的样子。而且，你知道，这是那种你可能会说，谁在乎呢，对吧？但我确实注意到当我一个月后换回普通鼠标时，
It's a vertical mouse, and so it's very hard to describe. No, I don't think it is it's if you put your hand straight out normally you hold the mouse with your palm towards the desk instead you hold it with your palm facing your keyboard if you're right-handed or left-handed with your palm facing your keyboard and then you make like a pincher motion with your thumb yeah like imagine if you're gonna shake someone's hand oh there you. That's kind of like what your hand is going to look like or feel like all day. And it's really, you know, it's one of these things like you might say, well, who cares, right? But I actually noticed when I switched to regular mouse after about a month,
我感觉肩膀有紧张感之类的。所以这是，我认为……人体工程学专家，我想。但他们说的是，我猜，当你倾斜手掌向下时，你会交叉前臂的两根骨头。这会造成压力，特别是如果你连续工作很多小时的话。所以是的，Evoluent垂直鼠标，它不
I kind of feel like the tension in the shoulder and things like that. And so this is, I think the, and I'm not like a... Ergonomics. Ergonomics, you know, expert, I think. But what they say is, I guess, when you tilt your hand, you know, palm down, you cross the two bones in your forearm. And that causes stress, especially if you do it for many hours. So yeah, the Evoluent vertical mouse, it doesn't
一定非得是那一个。那只是我一直用的那个。我相信任何垂直鼠标都会很棒。但是的，去看看吧。有一大堆人体工程学解决方案。奇怪的是，我确实有一个这样的鼠标，它仍然让我有点困扰。所以对我有效的方法是即使使用普通鼠标，也用左手使用它，尽管我是右撇子。哦，我有一个朋友，坐在我旁边的同事就是那样做的。他实际上交替使用。我也在某种程度上这样做。是的。
have to be that one. That just happens to be the one I've always used. I'm sure any vertical mouse would be great. But yeah, check it out. There's a whole host of ergonomic solutions. Weirdly, I did have one of these mice and it was still bothering me a little. And so the thing that worked for me was even just using a normal mouse, but using it with my left hand, even though I'm right-handed. Oh, I have a friend who, a coworker who sits next to me who does that. He has, he actually alternates. I do somewhat as well. Yeah.
我确实有两只鼠标插在电脑上，但我发现出于某种奇怪的原因，我猜因为我用右手做很多其他任务，所以用左手操作鼠标对我来说效果很好。但人们会责备我，因为大多数用左手使用鼠标的人会交换按钮，所以你……哦，我会弄错的，通常右键点击是右边的按钮，但你把它变成外面的食指，你的食指应该是主要的点击，对吧？但我没有，我保留了它，这对我来说太令人困惑了。哦，所以我使用……我保留了
I do have two mice plugged into my computer actually, but I find for some weird reason, I guess because I do a lot of other tasks with my right arm, that using my left arm for my mouse works really well for me but then people fuss at me because most people who use their mice with their left hand swap the buttons so you oh i'm gonna get this wrong normally to right click it's the you know right button but you make it the outside index your index finger should be the main click right but i don't i leave it that is too confusing to me oh so i use i leave
它在正常的方向，所以我用我的中指进行主要的点击。哦，哇。所以是的，我将非常擅长导航交通，就像你的中指已经准备好了。我甚至不知道你在说什么，我试图找出说这一切的正确方式。好的，继续前进，那不是说那句话的正确方式。继续前进，尴尬的笑话。我的本期工具是3D打印机，也试图符合主题。如果你进入业余机器人技术，你肯定会想要有一台3D打印机，或者有一台也不会有什么坏处。我有一台，我们在节目中谈论过几次3D打印机。是的，我不知道
it in the normal orientation so i use my uh middle finger to do the main clicking oh wow it's so yeah i'm gonna be really uh adept at uh navigating traffic like your middle finger is just ready to go i didn't even know what you were saying i was trying to figure out the right way to say all right moving on that was not the right way to say that moving on awkward joke um my tool of the show is a 3d printer trying to be in theme as well if you get into hobby robotics you'll definitely uh want to have a 3d printer or it won't hurt to have one um and i got one we talked about 3d printers a couple times on the show yeah and i don't know
我是否谈论过我的，但我最终从套件中组装了一台。它是一种低成本的，RepRap Prusa i3的一个版本，我实际上不知道怎么说那个名字。它是那个的变体，我很享受它。它向我展示了很多关于那种东西的知识。我玩得很开心，我打印了很多东西，有些是功能性的，有些是好玩的，然后把它们涂上颜色。如果你有小孩，这很酷，因为他们认为你打印的任何东西，他们称之为机器人。所以像“爸爸，我想下楼看机器人”，他们只是看着它像那样四处移动。但你确实会进入这些阶段，或者我有几次，它需要大量的……因为我的属于低端，我猜，或者预算型的，但我认为高端的偶尔也需要这个。需要大量的调整
if i've talked about mine but um i did end up building one from a kit it's kind of a low cost one a version of one of the rep wraps uh rep wrap prussia i3 or prusa i3 i don't actually know how to say that um and it's a it's a variant of that i'm enjoying it it showed me a lot about that kind of stuff i've had a good time i printed a lot of things some functional some playful and then kind of painted them if you have little kids it's kind of cool because they think anything you print they think they call it the robot so like daddy i want to go downstairs and watch the robot uh and they just watch it kind of like zig and zag around um but then you do kind of get into these stages or i have a couple times where it requires a lot of or because mine's a low-end one i guess or budget one but i think the high-end ones do need this occasionally too needs like a lot of tuning
来保持它处于良好状态。所以有时它会失去校准之类的，你花了几次时间，你只是想下楼打印点东西，但它不工作，你试图修复它，所以你花了很多时间做那个。明白了。你有什么推荐的吗？因为我一直想要一台。我的意思是，我有的那台有一组特定的问题，我觉得在我的能力范围内，为了省钱是可以接受的。所以我的Folger Tech 2020 i3，这意味着它使用20毫米乘20毫米的铝型材，它是Prusa i3变体。所以它相对便宜，但质量控制不太好，说明书虽然
to keep it in it in a good state and so sometimes it gets like out of calibration or whatever and you spend several like sessions where you kind of just want to go down and print something but it's not working and you're trying to like fix it so you spend a fair amount of time doing that gotcha do you have one that you recommend because i've always wanted one um i mean so the one i have has a specific set of problems that i felt were okay within my wheelhouse for me to save some money um so mine is the folger tech 2020 i3 which means that uses aluminum extrusion 20 millimeters by 20 millimeters and it's the prussia i3 variant so it's relatively cheap um but the quality control isn't great and the instructions although
足够了，你需要习惯于组装套件，特别是硬件东西，否则你可能会非常困惑。所以比如如何让它进入正交状态，所有各种部件都正确对齐，需要相当多的了解它应该如何工作，才知道要松开什么，拧紧什么，调整什么。我甚至不能组装宜家家具。哦，是的，那你肯定不想要这一台。所以还有一些价格更高的，但很多人推荐LulzBot Taz。我没用过，我想他们现在出到Taz6了，但那台看起来很不错。你知道，你可以看看，Reddit上有很多社区，RepRap社区。
adequate you need to have be used to building kits of things specifically hardware things before or you'll probably be very confused so like how to get it into kind of orthogonal conditions where all of the various pieces are aligned properly takes a fair bit of kind of knowing how that should work to know what to loosen and what to tighten and adjust and i can't even build ikea furniture oh yeah then you do not want this one um so then there are ones that are you know moving up the price scale but like a lot of people recommend the lulzbot taz um i've not used i think they're at taz6 now but that one seems pretty good you know you can look there's a lot of communities on reddit um the reprap community
足够了，你需要习惯于组装各种套件，特别是硬件套件，否则你可能会感到非常困惑。比如如何将其调整到正交状态，使所有部件都正确对齐，这需要相当多的经验来判断该松开哪里、拧紧哪里以及如何调整。我连宜家家具都组装不了。哦，那你就绝对不想要这一款。嗯，那么还有一些价格更高一点的，很多人推荐 Lulzbot Taz。我没用过，我想他们现在出到 Taz 6 了，但那款看起来相当不错。你知道，你可以去看看，Reddit 上有很多社区，比如 RepRap 社区。
is is pretty big and there's some a lot of clones from china and elsewhere that are varying levels of sophistication and goodness or badness and it all depends on what you want to do with it and how hands-off or tinkering you want to be with it. Gotcha. But in my mind, half the fun is printing the upgrades for the machine. Like I've upgraded a lot of things on my machine. And I derive enjoyment from that. Oh, I see. Like what's an example of an upgrade you'd print?
这东西相当大，而且中国和其他地方有很多克隆产品，它们的复杂程度和好坏程度各不相同，这完全取决于你想用它做什么，以及你想要多大程度的“放手”或“折腾”。明白了。但在我看来，打印机器的升级件本身就是乐趣的一半。比如我给我的机器升级了很多东西，我从中获得了乐趣。哦，我明白了。比如你打印的升级件有什么例子吗？
Sure. So, oh, this is going to get really detailed and hard to explain in words but the there's the in this style the bed moves forward and backwards but not left or right or up and down so the okay piece of glass or pcb you know that you're printing on moves only forward and backwards then there's a set of screws that hang down from the top of the machine that uh the actual print head rides on and moves up and down and then another motor to move it left and right so that assembly can slide up and down on these screws but the screws they ship with it are just like cheap same thing you would use for like low end bolts they're not actually what you would typically use for a control system like that a high quality screw and so i switched out those
当然。这个说起来会非常详细，很难用语言解释，但在这种结构中，打印床前后移动，但不左右或上下移动。所以，你打印的玻璃或PCB板只做前后移动。然后机器顶部垂下一组螺杆，实际的打印头在上面上下移动，还有另一个电机负责左右移动。所以那个组件可以在这些螺杆上上下滑动，但它们自带的螺杆就像廉价的低端螺栓，并不是那种控制系统通常会用的高质量螺杆，所以我把它们换掉了。
screws to the more high quality screws they're called lead screws um so that as it moves up it does it more precisely which means the prints are more even in each layer and so you get a little less noise you didn't 3d print the screw so no so you buy the screw but then how the screw connects to the side holder parts i don't have a technical description but like that needs to be re-3d printed because it's it uses a different nut than the original one and so you 3d print that i 3d printed like little feet that go under the bottom so that when it vibrates, it doesn't vibrate the table. So it's quieter. This sounds so fun.
换成了更高质量的螺杆，它们被称为丝杠。这样它上下移动时会更精确，意味着每一层的打印效果更均匀，噪音也更小。你没有3D打印那个螺杆吧？没有，螺杆是买的，但螺杆与侧面支架部分的连接方式——我没有专业术语描述——需要重新3D打印，因为它用的螺母和原来的不一样。我还打印了底部的小脚垫，这样机器震动时就不会带动桌子震动，所以更安静了。听起来真有趣。
3D printed like little holders to like, you know, route the cables. Yeah, just like all sorts of little things. Yeah, I mean, I've had so many like things I've wanted to 3D print. But I don't I actually I have access to a 3D printer now. But but for a i actually uh i have access to a 3d printer now but uh but for a while i didn't have access to a 3d printer and even like uh you know the uh thomas the train like wooden train tracks yeah like i if i had a 3d printer i mean oh my gosh like it would be so epic yeah so i did print like there's a set of low polygon count uh pokemon models that my kids love so i've printed them
3D打印了一些小支架来整理线缆之类的。是的，各种各样的小东西。我的意思是，我有太多想3D打印的东西了。但我现在其实能接触到3D打印机了。不过有一段时间我没有，比如托马斯小火车的木制轨道，如果我有3D打印机，天哪，那会太棒了。我确实打印了一套低多边形的宝可梦模型，我的孩子们很喜欢，所以我打印了。
i don't even know how many now like little bulbasaur and squirtles and charmanders uh so they love those and theme with the pokemon go um and like i printed a lightsaber so like the lightsaber hilt or whatever and a bunch of pieces that was pretty cool so i've printed a lot of things that kind of just work pretty seamlessly and then i'm trying to get into kind of designing my own parts for various ideas that i have so that's that goes a little slower though very cool all right talking about robotics robotics so this will be a little different in the structure of how we talk about it because i didn't we could talk about the history of robotics but i don't know yeah i mean that's it's probably enormous and not that relevant. So the reason why I find robotics interesting
我都不知道打印了多少个了，什么妙蛙种子、杰尼龟、小火龙之类的，他们很喜欢，还有宝可梦GO的主题。我还打印了一个光剑，包括剑柄和一堆零件，挺酷的。所以我打印了很多能无缝衔接的东西，现在我正尝试为我的一些想法设计自己的零件，不过进度有点慢。非常酷。好了，谈谈机器人技术。这部分我们的讨论结构会有点不同，因为我不知道……我们可以谈谈机器人历史，但我不知道……是的，那可能太庞大了，而且没那么相关。所以我发现机器人技术有趣的原因是
and the little bit of work I've done with it from the hobbyist and not, is that it's a lot of systems that need to work together to kind of have a robot. And so we're going to kind of go through each of the, or some of the various subsystems that make up a robot, because a robot is different than just an application where it's a binary running on a computer. It is often many different applications. They need to do a huge spectrum of different areas of expertise because they all are needed for having a successful robot. So the first one that I guess everyone kind of thinks about, and I'm not going to talk about since this is programming throwdown, we're going to talk about this as it applies to software. So we're not going to talk about things like mechanical design of the robot, but that is also a very interesting topic. So the first one is the things that move or control or interact with the world and the controls for them.
以及我作为业余爱好者所做的一点工作，是因为它涉及许多需要协同工作的系统才能构成一个机器人。所以我们将逐一介绍构成机器人的各个子系统，因为机器人不同于运行在计算机上的单一应用程序。它通常是许多不同的应用程序。它们需要涵盖极其广泛的专业领域，因为要制造一个成功的机器人，这些都是必需的。我想大家首先想到的是——既然这是Programming Throwdown节目，我们从软件的角度来谈——我们不谈机器人的机械设计，尽管那也是一个非常有趣的话题。所以第一个是移动、控制或与世界交互的部件及其控制系统。
So these are, you know, you could think of um what moves the robot so most robots we think of move around the world in some way so maybe it's wheels that are attached to motors and those motors spin the wheels and move the robot forward or you have you know a robot arm and it has actuators little motors at each each joint um it could be i'm trying to think of other things uh treads for a tank style robot there's all sorts of different things about how do you move a robot um and then there's things about manipulating the world like i have a little claw and i want to grasp the world or i want to i'm trying to think like things where you want to interact with something physically
你可以想象一下是什么在驱动机器人。我们认为大多数机器人以某种方式在世界上移动，比如连接到电机的轮子，电机旋转轮子使机器人前进；或者你有一个机器人手臂，每个关节都有执行器（小电机）；或者坦克式机器人的履带。关于如何移动机器人有各种各样的东西。还有操纵世界的部分，比如我有一个小爪子，我想抓取物体，或者我想……我在想那些你想在物理上与某物交互的场景。
in your world versus just moving through it. And a lot of these have that in common. They're combined with what we're going to talk about next sensors, but you have some sort of motor or a electromechanical muscle of some sort that's moving and you need to control that. And so there's software that needs to be written to say, if I want to move precisely from uh you know one millimeter forward how do we do that and there's
而不是仅仅穿过它。很多这些系统都有共同点。它们与我们接下来要谈的传感器相结合，但你有一些电机或某种机电肌肉在运动，你需要控制它。所以需要编写软件来决定，如果我想精确移动一毫米，该怎么做？这里有
kind of two approaches there and there's a lot of software around this but one is open loop that's the easiest so that is i know that if i have a stepper motor which each time i kind of move the stepper motor forward it moves a set number of degrees. So like 1.7 degrees forward. This is like, I guess, if you had a tire. Yeah. And you know that if you rotate the tire 360 degrees, you know the radius of the tire,
两种方法，围绕这个有很多软件。一种是开环控制，这是最简单的。我知道如果我有一个步进电机，每次我让它向前移动，它就会移动固定的角度。比如向前移动1.7度。这就像，我想，如果你有一个轮胎。是的。你知道如果你把轮胎旋转360度，你也知道轮胎的半径，
you can kind of guess pretty accurately how far you're going to go. So that's a great example. So if you're going to like roll forward on a tire, you wouldn't necessarily do that closed loop because there's a big problem which is as you roll forward the tire probably slips a little and so at the end you don't exactly know how far forward you went so even if you have an encoder on the wheel to see physically how much did the wheel move you aren't able to measure like via the wheel itself you aren't able to measure if it slipped at all okay and so that that would be kind of something you would do open loop most often you would just kind of drive it and you would rely on some other
你可以相当准确地猜出你会走多远。这是一个很好的例子。所以如果你要用轮胎向前滚动，你不一定会用闭环控制，因为有一个大问题，那就是当你向前滚动时，轮胎可能会打滑，所以最后你并不确切知道你向前走了多远。即使你在轮子上安装了编码器来物理测量轮子转了多少，你也无法通过轮子本身测量它是否打滑了。好的，所以这通常会用开环控制，你只是驱动它，然后依靠其他
sensor to tell you how far you went but then you have closed loop so closed loop is like a servo so if you've ever used a servo of any sort before, you kind of tell it to go to a specific angle. So like I want to go to angle 90 and I want to go to angle 95. And it has circuitry inside of it that tries to keep it at that angle. So even if you go push on it, it'll try to go back to the set position. But there's software in a lot of these systems that does that. It's called
传感器来告诉你走了多远。但后来有了闭环控制，闭环就像伺服电机。如果你以前用过任何伺服电机，你会告诉它去一个特定的角度。比如我想去90度，我想去95度。它内部有电路试图把它保持在那个角度。所以即使你去推它，它也会试图回到设定的位置。很多这些系统中都有软件在做这件事。这被称为
closed loop and this is where you get into stuff if you've ever heard um pid which is like proportional integral differential or derivative control so this is a way of keeping something at a set level and this gets into control theory and in closed loop you're sending out a control signal for something to happen and then you're measuring what happens back and you could have all sorts of problems where you don't want to but you're trying to go for a certain position and you overshoot it and then you need to move back and there's all sorts of math around how do you try to prevent overshoot how do you try to prevent that like over time it stays very close to it?
闭环控制，这就是你如果听说过PID（比例-积分-微分控制）会接触到的东西。这是一种将某物保持在设定水平的方法，这涉及控制理论。在闭环中，你发出一个控制信号让某事发生，然后测量反馈回来的结果。你可能会遇到各种问题，比如你试图达到某个位置却超调了，然后你需要移回来。这里有各种数学方法来尝试防止超调，以及如何确保它随着时间推移保持在非常接近目标的位置。
Does this involve calculating the gradient or something and moving step, like adaptive gradient or something? Yeah, so there's different ways. So there's, like I said, the PID loop. Other things you'll hear about sort of in this arena are like Kalman filters start to come in can come into this this isn't meant we all probably later go into more topics this is kind of giving you google words that you can go search or maybe context if you've heard some of these words before but this would be you
这是否涉及计算梯度之类的，然后移动步长，比如自适应梯度？是的，有不同的方法。正如我所说，有PID回路。在这个领域你还会听到像卡尔曼滤波之类的东西。这并不是说我们现在要深入探讨所有主题，这只是给你一些可以去谷歌搜索的关键词，或者如果你以前听过这些词，提供一些背景。但这就是
know closed loop is trying to say how do i have a desired outcome and then how do i make sure i achieve that outcome in a good manner gotcha that makes sense so closed loop has to be something kind of simple like like uh turning a rudder on a on a boat or yeah holding a rudder at a specific position on the boat yeah or holding a robot arm at a specific level or even things like you know we were talking about before like a 3d printer so my 3d printer has like the nozzle that heats up the plastic. You want to hold it at a very specific temperature, but that's not as simple as just setting an amount of current to flow through. Because as the room temperature changes, as plastic flows out, like cold plastic comes in and then hot plastic goes
闭环控制，试图解决如何获得预期的结果，以及如何确保以良好的方式实现该结果。明白了，这很有道理。所以闭环控制必须是某种简单的东西，比如在船上转动舵，或者在船上把舵保持在特定位置，或者把机器人手臂保持在特定水平。甚至像我们之前谈到的3D打印机，我的3D打印机有加热塑料的喷嘴。你想把它保持在非常特定的温度，但这不像设置电流大小那么简单。因为随着室温变化，随着塑料流出，冷塑料进入，热塑料流出，
out, the temperature moves around a lot. And ideally you would like it to be very stable at a very specific temperature. And so there's a control loop where somebody in software is measuring from a thermometer the temperature of the piece of metal that is the nozzle and controlling the heater that heats up that piece of metal and so there's actually a control loop running there to try to keep at a very stable temperature okay that makes sense so do sense. So it sounds like with closed loop, you just like someone else has kind of done it for you. But with open loop, the kind of onus is on you. Like maybe you have a camera or something
温度会波动很大。理想情况下，你希望它在特定温度下非常稳定。所以有一个控制回路，软件中的某处正在通过温度计测量作为喷嘴的金属片的温度，并控制加热该金属片的加热器。所以那里确实运行着一个控制回路，试图保持非常稳定的温度。好的，这很有道理。所以听起来闭环控制就像是别人已经为你做好了，但开环控制，责任就在你身上。比如你可能有一个摄像头之类的，
and you're the one who has to say, I'm really close to the wall right now or something like that. Yeah, so I mean, open loop. So these are just, it's kind of separate from actuators. How do you control something? How do you move? and then these are various ways when you move things kind of how are they moved whether you do them in open loop or in a closed loop um so so for things like sensors there's a whole a whole bunch of questions so you could use a sensor to try to you'll hear people
而你必须说：“我现在离墙很近了”之类的。是的，开环控制。这些与执行器是分开的。你如何控制某物？你如何移动？这些是当你移动物体时，你是以开环还是闭环方式移动的各种方法。对于传感器，有一大堆问题。你可以使用传感器来尝试，你会听到人们
say close the loop so i moved you know i told my robot wheels to move forward and we talked before about structure from motion like i look at the camera and tried to guess how far forward did i move to quote unquote close the loop so that even though i didn't measure anything about the motor i looked at the world around me and say the world shifted forward a foot therefore like i know what i just did to the motor if i do that again i will most likely move forward one foot again oh is that where the phrase close the loop came from uh i they're related they're related i don't know which one came first that's interesting well it's interesting i never thought about you know every time i've
说“闭环”。我告诉我的机器人轮子向前移动，我们之前谈过“运动结构恢复”（Structure from Motion），我看着摄像头，试图猜测我向前移动了多远，从而“闭环”。这样即使我没有测量电机，我也观察了周围的世界，说世界向前移动了一英尺，因此我知道我刚才对电机做了什么。如果我再做一次，我很可能会再次向前移动一英尺。哦，这就是“闭环”这个短语的由来吗？它们是相关的，我不知道哪个先出现，这很有趣。嗯，这很有趣，我从来没想过，每次我
said close the loop it's like you know talking to somebody or something yeah so when you close the loop with a human you did something and then something happened and closing the loop means like getting feedback back so you know what to change next time yeah that makes sense yeah it makes sense so the camera the camera gives you the feedback, yep. That potentially could give you the feedback that then turns into more actions for the wheels. It then changes the camera. And so now you have a closed loop. Yep.
说“闭环”时，就像是在和某人交谈之类的。是的，所以当你与人闭环时，你做了一些事，然后发生了一些事，闭环意味着获得反馈，这样你就知道下次该改变什么。是的，这很有道理。所以摄像头提供了反馈，是的。这可能提供反馈，然后转化为轮子的更多动作。它又改变了摄像头。所以现在你就有了一个闭环。是的。
And so there's things like, you know, for sensors themselves, we'll talk about in a second. But like, often you'll have a camera and you want to point the camera at a specific direction. But if you think about, oh, like, you know, quadcopters are really popular now, these helicopters with four blades, but they kind of move and bounce around in the air. It would be ideal for some of them if you held the camera pointing at a very specific thing. And so how do you do that?
对于传感器本身，我们稍后再谈。但通常你会有一个摄像头，你想把摄像头指向特定的方向。但如果你想想，哦，比如四轴飞行器现在很流行，这些有四个叶片的直升机，它们在空中移动和弹跳。如果其中一些能保持摄像头指向非常特定的物体，那将是理想的。那么你该怎么做呢？
You have a set of motors that are able to move the camera, but they need to monitor what the quadcopter is doing and kind of cancel that motion out and so that's a closed loop system that gimbal system for trying to control that camera and that is so that the sensor the camera itself gets a good image and so then there's a lot of work associated with sensors themselves how so we talked about a lot of things there for sensors but someone still has to write the code to talk to these pieces of hardware and like read ultimately they're probably producing some electrical signal or the hardware itself is producing bytes that need to be read but you need to interact with those pieces of hardware
你有一组电机能够移动摄像头，但它们需要监控四轴飞行器在做什么，并抵消那种运动。所以这是一个闭环系统，那个云台系统就是为了控制摄像头，这样传感器（摄像头本身）就能获得好的图像。所以关于传感器本身有很多工作要做。怎么说呢？我们谈到了传感器的很多东西，但仍然有人必须编写代码来与这些硬件交互，并读取它们。最终它们可能产生某种电信号，或者硬件本身产生需要读取的字节，但你需要与这些硬件交互，
and make it into something that the rest of the system understands. So for a camera, that would be reading out a single frame off the camera. For an accelerometer, it would be configuring the range of sensitivity for the accelerometer and then reading out the current acceleration that you're experiencing. So there's a lot of work around how do you do that for the sensors? How do you read it in? How do you read it in? How do you put it in a format that makes sense for the rest of your system? And then how do you do it at like a set interval quickly enough so that you're not – sometimes I read it a little early and sometimes I read it a little late
并将其转化为系统其余部分能理解的东西。对于摄像头，那将是从摄像头读取单帧图像。对于加速度计，那将是配置加速度计的灵敏度范围，然后读取你正在经历的当前加速度。所以关于如何为传感器做这些工作有很多工作要做。如何读取它？如何将其放入对系统其余部分有意义的格式中？然后如何以设定的间隔足够快地完成它，这样你就不会——有时我读得早一点，有时读得晚一点，
because that can cause problems with some of the stuff we'll talk later. But a lot of things in a robotic system are assumed to be running at a very specific rate. So this is similar to like in a video game you want it to run at whatever 60 frames per second and so you want everything to kind of always be at that and if it if you had 60 frames in a second but you had all 60 right at the beginning of the second it would look very weird so you actually want 60 evenly spaced frames and so that's called the jitter how much time the time between frames how often it does and so when you're reading sensors you're trying to kind of reduce jitter
因为这会导致我们稍后要谈的一些问题。但机器人系统中的许多东西都被假定以非常特定的速率运行。这类似于电子游戏，你希望它以每秒60帧的速度运行，所以你希望一切总是那样。如果你在一秒钟内有60帧，但所有60帧都在一秒钟的开头，那看起来会很奇怪。所以你实际上想要60个均匀间隔的帧，这被称为抖动（Jitter），即帧之间的时间间隔。所以当你读取传感器时，你是在尝试减少抖动，
make sure that the you're reading it at the set rate there's a lot of work about that as well gotcha that makes sense um yeah a big part of robotics too is is planning and automity. So one is autonomy. So one is teleoperators. This would be like, I guess, using a joystick and just when you press a trigger down, the helicopter blades turn faster or something like that. There's also just purely autonomous
确保你以设定的速率读取它。关于这一点也有很多工作要做。明白了，这很有道理。机器人技术的很大一部分也是规划和自主性。一个是自主性。一个是远程操作。这就像，我想，使用操纵杆，当你按下扳机时，直升机叶片转得更快之类的。还有纯粹的自主，
where you give it kind of very high level instructions and someone's built all sorts of layers of, I guess, machine learning and different kind of planning systems. So, in other words, like the very top layer could say, you know, fly to this spot on a map and then fly back and land. And so at that level, if you're doing any sort of machine learning there, you're probably not doing any machine learning there. It's probably a human putting in certain commands based on sort of changes that they want to make in the world or things that they want to see in the world. So that's sort of like human-level decision-making.
你给它非常高级的指令，有人构建了各种层级的机器学习和不同的规划系统。换句话说，最顶层可以说：“飞到地图上的这个点，然后飞回来降落。”在那个层面上，如果你在那里做任何机器学习，你可能根本没在做机器学习。这可能是一个人类根据他们想要在世界上做出的改变或想要看到的东西输入某些命令。所以这有点像人类水平的决策。
Then when you go back, when you kind of go see in the world. So that's sort of like human level decision making. Then when you go back, when you kind of go down in the stack, it would be things like, there's usually some kind of a state machine where it says, okay, am I landing? Am I taking off? Am I flying to a destination? Am I trying to take a picture or something?
然后当你回到……当你深入堆栈时，通常会有某种状态机，它说：“好的，我是在降落吗？我是在起飞吗？我是在飞往目的地吗？我是在尝试拍照吗？”
I'm thinking of drones here, right? and at the bottom level are things like are kind of like a system for each of those states like um you know the drone is taking off here's sort of a bunch of logic to kind of handle the takeoff scenario and did it for all the other kind of scenarios. Yeah, I think each of the different, if you think about subsystems in, for instance, like, you know, a quadcopter, you have something that's trying to keep the helicopter afloat, like don't crash. But then you have something else trying to say,
我这里想到的是无人机。在底层，每个状态都有某种系统，比如“无人机正在起飞，这里有一堆逻辑来处理起飞场景”，并为所有其他场景做同样的事。是的，我认为每个不同的子系统，比如四轴飞行器，你有一些东西试图让直升机保持漂浮，比如“别坠毁”。但你还有其他东西试图说，
you know, move forward. So there's an interaction between like go forward and do it stably. Like you don't want it, you know, kind forward. So there's an interaction between like, go forward and do it stably. Like you don't want it, you know, kind of going crazy. You want it to go forward smoothly and deal with any kind of disturbances along that. And then as you said, there's something more, which is like, I'm trying to get from point A to point B. And so like, what's the best path to get there um another part of it is like supervised learning and so what this is is um like what's a good example um this isn't i should have done this as a tool of the show i've been doing the udacity uh machine learning class with sebastian run the self-driving
“向前移动”。所以“向前走”和“稳定地做”之间存在交互。你不想让它发疯。你希望它平稳地向前移动，并处理沿途的任何干扰。正如你所说，还有更多，比如“我正试图从A点到B点”。所以什么是到达那里的最佳路径？另一部分是监督学习。这是一个很好的例子……我不应该把它作为节目的工具，我一直在和Sebastian Thrun一起做Udacity的机器学习课程，那个自动驾驶
car one yeah uh yes And he talks in there. So I definitely recommend that. I've never really sat down and did a massively online class, but I finally did, and I did it with this one. And I cheated. I didn't really do the homework. I just went watching all the videos. How are you going to do the puzzle contest
汽车的课程。是的，他在里面谈到了。所以我绝对推荐那个。我从来没有真正坐下来做过大规模在线课程，但我终于做了，我做了这个。而且我作弊了，我没有真正做作业，我只是看了所有的视频。如果你连Udacity的作业都做不了，
if you can't even do the Udacity homework? But I've been watching, and I found it really a good, well-put-together series. And so if you're interested in robotics, I would definitely recommend it. And so the example they use there in supervised learning is that when you're driving an autonomous car, you want, for instance, to decide if the terrain you're currently driving on necessitates that you drive fast or slow. And so over time, they collected a bunch of data when they were driving a car and looked at things like the accelerometer for how bumpy the road was. And I forget they used something else as an example. Oh, the current gradient, like whether it was flat or steep or very steep.
你怎么去参加拼图比赛？但我一直在看，我发现它是一个非常好的、组织良好的系列。所以如果你对机器人技术感兴趣，我绝对推荐它。他们在监督学习中使用的例子是，当你驾驶自动驾驶汽车时，你想要决定你当前行驶的地形是否需要你开得快或慢。随着时间的推移，他们在驾驶汽车时收集了一堆数据，并观察了诸如加速度计（路面有多颠簸）之类的事情。我忘了他们还用了什么作为例子。哦，当前的坡度，比如它是平坦的、陡峭的还是非常陡峭的。
And so they recorded these various things while they were driving and produced a data set where they the label was either they were driving fast or driving slow and so supervised learning would be saying giving that to a computer and then saying hey next time i give you a current bumpiness and gradient i want you to tell me if i should drive fast or slow but i give it a bunch of examples of what i did to supervise it and how to make that prediction right and actually they did the same thing for alpha go the world champion go player um they actually you know because if you imagine like in go there could be actually many different ways to play really good go and trying to find all of them or trying to find one of them could be could
所以他们在驾驶时记录了这些不同的东西，并生成了一个数据集，标签是“开得快”或“开得慢”。监督学习就是把这些给计算机，然后说：“嘿，下次我给你当前的颠簸程度和坡度，我想要你告诉我我应该开得快还是慢。”但我给了它一堆我为了监督它而做的例子，以及如何做出那个预测。实际上，他们在AlphaGo（世界围棋冠军）上也做了同样的事情。他们实际上……因为如果你想象一下，在围棋中，实际上有很多不同的方式可以下出非常好的围棋，试图找到所有这些方式或者试图找到其中一种可能
be really really hard so what they did is they said let's take all of the games played by all of the world champions and in the beginning when they're when they just start learning instead of trying to play have the computer play go against itself and get better that way which is what they do later but in the beginning they just say look computer this was a game played by two experts um the next time you see games like this i want you to play as good as these experts do so like in other words take these, this bank of games played by these experts and try to generalize it. And so this changes the objective function from, you know, play the best possible game ago to just do what these experts do, which is much, much easier. And then that was sort of a scaffold. Once they they have that then the system is kind of already
非常非常困难。所以他们所做的是，他们说：“让我们采用所有世界冠军下的所有棋局。”在刚开始学习时，与其让计算机自己下围棋并以此进步（这是他们后来做的），在开始时，他们只是说：“看，计算机，这是一场由两位专家下的棋局，下次你看到这样的棋局时，我想要你像这些专家一样下得好。”换句话说，采用这些由专家下的棋局库，并尝试概括它。这改变了目标函数，从“下出尽可能好的围棋”变成了“只做这些专家所做的事”，这要容易得多。然后那是一种脚手架。一旦他们有了那个，系统就已经
tuned to a certain spot of the search space um so in other words like to to illustrate like if all the experts in go for some reason always place the first stone on the bottom left for some reason like it's just a thing then you can learn all sorts of cool strategies where you don't do that but it's not going to help, especially if you're going second. So you might as well learn what the experts do and then optimize after that. And so the self-driving car is the same way. You can't just train a model and then have a self-driving car go on version zero of the model and just drive off a cliff.
调整到了搜索空间的某个位置。换句话说，为了说明这一点，如果围棋界的所有专家出于某种原因总是把第一颗棋子放在左下角，那它就是一种习惯，那么你可以学习各种很酷的策略，而不必那样做，但这不会有帮助，特别是如果你是后手的话。所以你最好学习专家所做的，然后在此基础上进行优化。自动驾驶汽车也是一样。你不能只是训练一个模型，然后让自动驾驶汽车在模型的0版本上行驶，然后直接冲下悬崖。
It would be a disaster. So instead, you build this supervised model and then you can even while you're driving you know see oh what would the model do and if and if you're going 45 and the model says i would go 130 130 miles an hour then you know something's like really busted yeah and and i think interesting you talked about like levels you know know, first it's kind of remote control, then you kind of move up. And if you think about like autonomous cars as an example, even though the end result, you want a fully autonomous car where you just say, I want to go to the grocery store and it just takes you there. You kind of, as you're building up that system,
那将是一场灾难。所以相反，你构建这个监督模型，然后即使在你驾驶时，你也可以看到：“哦，模型会怎么做？”如果你的车速是45英里，而模型说：“我会开到130英里”，那么你就知道有些地方真的坏了。是的，我认为你谈到的层级很有趣，你知道，首先是遥控，然后你向上移动。如果你以自动驾驶汽车为例，即使最终结果是你想要一辆完全自动驾驶的汽车，你只需要说“我想去杂货店”，它就会带你去。当你构建那个系统时，
you take it through various levels where initially you just want to test that you can kind of tell the car what to do and it does it. Then eventually you're kind of monitoring what it does, like allow it to do some stuff. So that would be like cruise control, like set the car on cruise control and it knows to just try to keep that speed. Then,
你会让它经历不同的层级。最初你只是想测试你能告诉汽车做什么，它就做了。然后最终你是在监控它在做什么，比如允许它做一些事情。那就像巡航控制，比如把车设为巡航控制，它知道只需尝试保持那个速度。然后，
you know, you're giving it a task, go the speed and stay in a lane. Then you're going it a task. Go the speed and stay in a lane. Then you're going like, okay, now I want you to figure out how to change lanes on your own. And then a step past that, it's like, I don't care how you do it. You pick the roads. You pick the lanes. You pick the speed.
你知道，你给它一个任务：保持速度并保持在车道内。然后你给它一个任务：保持速度并保持在车道内。然后你给它：“好的，现在我想要你自己弄清楚如何换道。”再进一步，就像：“我不在乎你怎么做。你选择道路，你选择车道，你选择速度。”
I just want to go from here to here. And you kind of take it up through that level of sophistication. Right. Yep. And that's something that we still haven't done with a lot of systems like we don't have a lot of fully autonomous systems even things like the drones you hear about being used for war aren't autonomous and it's scary what will happen when they finally do go fully autonomous but you don't tell them protect this area or you know go
“我只是想从这里到这里。”你把它提升到那个复杂程度。对。是的。这是我们仍然没有在很多系统中做到的事情。我们没有很多完全自主的系统，即使是你听说用于战争的无人机也不是自主的。当它们最终完全自主时，会发生什么，这很可怕。但你不会告诉它们“保护这个区域”或“去
take this action they have some combination of humans telling them you know fly this way and like you know get home right but like they aren't sitting in an area looking for something to do we don't have robots that yet or at least not commonplace where a robot kind of replaces a mall cop and there's just a robot you know sitting in the mall watching for bad behavior and then like setting off a siren if it sees someone doing something bad um yeah exactly i mean there's this saying uh uh there's this sort of like thought experiment you know if if if a robot if you have a robot made and the kids are like really hungry, what's the stop the robot made from like microwaving the cat? It's like, it's like you need like all of those kind of really higher level things that involve
采取这个行动”。它们有一些人类的组合告诉它们“飞向这边”和“回家”之类的。但它们并没有坐在一个区域寻找事情做。我们还没有那种机器人，或者至少不是随处可见，比如一个机器人取代商场保安，只是一个机器人坐在商场里观察不良行为，然后如果看到有人做坏事就拉响警报。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，有一个说法，有一个思想实验：如果你制造了一个机器人，孩子们真的很饿，什么能阻止机器人把猫放进微波炉里？你需要所有那些涉及
sort of the fact that like, you know, different, different, like the fact that like, you know, ants like have a different like level of feelings as as as a as a cat and so you could step on an ant you can't step on a cat like these these things or you can't kill a cat i guess these things are are like incredibly entrenched in like our psychology and like very difficult and we haven't even like begun to to to sort of like crack these problems. So yeah, as Patrick said, because you're so much about, oh, you know, Skynet is coming, things like that.
某种事实的东西，比如蚂蚁和猫有不同程度的感受，所以你可以踩死一只蚂蚁，但你不能踩死一只猫。这些东西深深植根于我们的心理中，非常困难，我们甚至还没有开始解决这些问题。所以，正如Patrick所说，因为你谈论了很多关于“天网要来了”之类的事情。
And it's not, like we're so far away from that. And so that's where the machine learning, I think comes in is we talked first about controls and motors, and then we talked about sensors. I mean, these things are highly deterministic and highly straightforward part of robotics. And once you have them working, you can kind of have a remote controlled robot, I guess. But the machine learning comes in when you start trying to say things which are a little more non deterministic, there are many ways to accomplish it. And what
事实并非如此，我们离那还很远。这就是机器学习发挥作用的地方。我们首先谈到了控制和电机，然后谈到了传感器。我的意思是，这些是机器人技术中高度确定性和高度直接的部分。一旦你让它们工作，我想你就可以拥有一个遥控机器人。但机器学习是在你开始尝试说一些非确定性的事情时发挥作用的，有很多方法可以完成它。而
Jason's indicating is exactly right. Just because we have something which can do a relatively mundane task doesn't mean we're suddenly close to something that knows how to do all tasks. Yeah, exactly. Or even something that is self-aware, like that knows that it's doing a task and sort of what that means. So then another something to consider with robotics is often you may have many processors for a large robot in the system, all responsible for doing different things. Like one's responsible for collecting all the camera data. One's responsible for collecting the sensor data. Another is responsible for route planning.
Jason所指出的完全正确。仅仅因为我们有一些能做相对平凡任务的东西，并不意味着我们突然接近了某种知道如何完成所有任务的东西。是的，完全正确。或者甚至是某种有自我意识的东西，比如知道它正在执行任务以及这意味着什么。那么机器人技术的另一个考虑因素是，对于大型机器人系统，你通常可能有多个处理器，每个处理器负责做不同的事情。比如一个负责收集所有摄像头数据，一个负责收集传感器数据，另一个负责路径规划。
And so all of these systems have to communicate with each other. And there needs to be, often they may not even be the same kinds of processors. Like some may be very small, low-cost processors. some may be very small low-cost processors some may be high-end fancy very good processors and you need a common way for them to interact and communicate with each other so that's something that as a robotist you have to work on and debug and then also sometimes you need a communication off of the robot so how do you keep a log of what's happening you call that telemetry what if you want to talk to another robot and the two robots should coordinate to do a task now you need a distributed algorithm for deciding like what to do with multiple robots and this is where you get things
所以所有这些系统都必须相互通信。而且通常它们甚至可能不是同一种处理器。有些可能是非常小、低成本的处理器，有些可能是高端、昂贵、非常好的处理器，你需要一种通用的方式让它们交互和通信。所以这是作为机器人专家你必须工作和调试的事情。然后有时你需要机器人之外的通信。你如何保存正在发生的事情的日志？你称之为遥测。如果你想与另一个机器人交谈，并且两个机器人应该协调完成一项任务，现在你需要一个分布式算法来决定如何处理多个机器人。这就是你得到
like swarm uh robots and swarm intelligence and that's another interesting exploration area of robotics yeah i've seen a lot of uh there was there was this paper that came out a long time ago. It's called Boyd's. And the whole idea was they studied a bunch of different bird. This person was fascinated with how birds fly in like a V or different shapes. They're very geometric. And how difficult that must be from within the frame of reference of one of the birds to sort of understand how to orient itself and what it found is if you have a few simple rules um you can actually get that kind of that
像“蜂群机器人”和“群体智能”之类的东西，这是机器人技术的另一个有趣的探索领域。是的，我见过很多……很久以前有一篇论文出来了。它叫Boids。整个想法是他们研究了一群不同的鸟。这个人对鸟类如何以V字形或其他形状飞行非常着迷。它们非常几何化。从其中一只鸟的参考系来看，理解如何定位自己是多么困难。它发现如果你有几个简单的规则，
flocking kind of effect i mean the rules are very simple like uh you know get a little bit away from the birds next to me but not too much away it was kind of like a like a force based like a graph uh force-based system and uh so so i think that uh that's a big part of it is understanding like when you have many different robots um sort of how does that complex adaptive system work and there's a lot of really interesting research there yeah so like emergent behavior and yeah right yeah there's that's a huge area of research and you know a very interesting thing to look at and understand yep another part of this is hci human uh human computer interaction and i think it's also called human machine interaction and this is just uh about sort of how you uh interact with with the
你实际上可以得到那种“群聚”效应。我的意思是规则非常简单，比如“离我旁边的鸟远一点，但不要太远”。这有点像基于力的图系统。所以我认为这是很大一部分，理解当你有很多不同的机器人时，那种复杂的自适应系统是如何工作的。那里有很多非常有趣的研究。是的，比如涌现行为。是的，没错。这是一个巨大的研究领域，也是一个非常有趣的研究和理解对象。是的，这的另一个部分是HCI（人机交互），我认为它也被称为人机交互，这只是关于你如何与
machines around you it's very the name is very straightforward but you know for example um you know the touch screen uh is kind of one of these things that's gone in and out of vogue. I mean, I remember when there were touchscreen laptops, and then people realized, or, you know, a lot of people realized it doesn't really make sense. And then there was the Newton, where it was a phone-like, you know, form factor, but it had a stylus. And now we have the iPhone style, right? And so these are all just advances in HCI, and they can cause radically different user behavior. If I have to pull out a stylus, then that adds friction to the experience. I might not do something quick like send a text message or check my email or something.
周围的机器交互。名字非常直观，但例如，触摸屏是那种时髦的东西之一。我的意思是，我记得有触摸屏笔记本电脑，然后人们意识到，或者很多人意识到它并没有多大意义。然后有了Newton，它是一种类似手机的外形，但有一个手写笔。现在我们有了iPhone风格，对吧？这些都是HCI的进步，它们会导致截然不同的用户行为。如果我必须拿出触控笔，那会增加体验的摩擦力。我可能不会做像发短信或查邮件之类的快速事情。
And so it's just hugely important. And it's kind of like that kind of gets right on the border of robotics because it involves a sensor and it involves kind of the outside world. Yeah, and I think the difference with robots than just like how do humans interact with machines is also robots move about in our world it sounds a little weird i guess but and humans perceive them out in the environment and so you need to understand what are you trying how do you want people to behave around the robot do you want them to ignore it do you want them to you know be friends with it? These are questions that are still very large open research projects.
所以它非常重要。它有点处于机器人技术的边缘，因为它涉及传感器，也涉及外部世界。是的，我认为机器人与人类如何与机器交互的区别还在于机器人会在我们的世界中移动。这听起来有点奇怪，但人类在环境中感知它们，所以你需要理解你想要人们如何围绕机器人表现。你想要他们忽略它吗？你想要他们和它做朋友吗？这些问题仍然是很大的开放研究项目。
But things like the self-driving car, what happens when you get into it? And when you're sitting in it, how does it make you feel? That sounds really weird, but ultimately, if you don't feel safe because of the way it's driving, even if the way it's driving is better than the way humans drive you're probably gonna be really freaked out so even if elon musk tells you everything's gonna be okay yeah so maybe they need like a little elon musk head to come up and say welcome to our car right but these are all things you have to think through if you have a machine out in the world and then there was that movie about it but i don't remember where the assistant
但像自动驾驶汽车这样的事情，当你进入它时会发生什么？当你坐在里面时，它让你感觉如何？这听起来很奇怪，但最终，如果你因为它的驾驶方式而感到不安全，即使它的驾驶方式比人类驾驶更好，你可能也会感到非常惊慌。所以即使埃隆·马斯克告诉你一切都会好起来的。是的，所以也许他们需要一个埃隆·马斯克的小头探出来说“欢迎来到我们的车”。对，但如果你在世界上有一台机器，这些都是你必须考虑的事情。然后有一部关于它的电影，但我记不清在哪里了，手机上的助手
on your phone and people kind of develop a bond with it and call it by name and instead of saying it they say he or she is it i robot is that right no everybody's a different one okay i know what movie you're talking about but i also forgot i didn't watch it but but yeah basically this is a real thing that if people project emotions onto these or will, what are you wanting to evoke? And so this is things like when you call into a phone line for customer service, right, that they call that a robot. I didn't actually think about it until just now, but like, I guess a phone answering robot. But they want you to efficiently get to where you are. And but they need you to behave in a where you are um and but they need you to
人们会和它建立一种联系，并叫它的名字，而不是说“它”，他们说“他”或“她”。是《我，机器人》吗？对吗？不，每个人都是不同的。好的，我知道你在说哪部电影，但我也忘了，我没看。但基本上，这是一个真实的事情，如果人们将情感投射到这些东西上，或者会，你想要唤起什么？所以这就像当你拨打客户服务电话时，他们称之为机器人。我直到刚才才想到这一点，但我想，大概是一个电话应答机器人。但他们希望你高效地到达你想去的地方。但他们需要你以一种……你所在的地方……但他们需要你
behave in a certain way to kind of get that so they have to interact with you very specifically and it's the same thing goes for robots that how should you put little eyes on the robot or not what like people will react differently depending on what you do. So actually, I saw something pretty awesome in the city, in San Francisco, downtown San Francisco. I saw on a light pole this poster that said, you know, gone missing. And it was like they had taken the template of, I guess if you lose your dog,
以某种方式行事以获得那种效果，所以他们必须以非常特定的方式与你互动。机器人也是如此，比如你应该给机器人装上小眼睛吗？人们会根据你的行为做出不同的反应。实际上，我在旧金山市中心看到了一些非常棒的东西。我在电线杆上看到一张海报，上面写着“走失”。他们似乎用了那种模板，我想如果你丢了狗的话，
most people just go into Google and type like, I lost my dog. And there's some Google Doc template because they all seem to look the same. And it has little things where you could tear off the bottom and call the number. But it was a person's Roomba. Like, I guess the battery ran out in their fence and the Roomba just went out of the backyard and went down the street or something. And it was like, lost Roomba.
大多数人只会去谷歌搜索“我丢了狗”。然后会有一个谷歌文档模板，因为它们看起来都一样。上面有可以撕下来的小纸条，可以拨打上面的电话。但那是一个人的Roomba扫地机器人。我想可能是电池在围栏里耗尽了，Roomba就跑出了后院，沿着街道走丢了之类的。上面写着“丢失的Roomba”。
Like, if you find him, please cuddle him. Wait, that sounds like it's just a joke. I don't know. there was some well we'll see we'll see i think that i think it was written in a funny way but i think the person legit lost the room okay yeah i do know a lot of people call the roomba like him or her like or at least they have name a name for the roomba so interesting so then I was just uh to close out going to talk about various things where people hear about robotics we already talked about self-driving cars drones um you know these are things but also there's first robotics so
比如，如果你找到了它，请抱抱它。等等，这听起来像是个玩笑。我不知道。有人……好吧，我们走着瞧。我觉得它写得很有趣，但我认为那个人是真的丢了Roomba。好吧，我知道很多人把Roomba称为“他”或“她”，或者至少他们会给Roomba起个名字。真有趣。那么，为了结束这个话题，我将谈谈人们听说过的各种机器人技术。我们已经讨论过自动驾驶汽车、无人机，这些都是，但还有FIRST机器人竞赛，
that I think they have various degrees for middle school and high school students and these are remote controlled robots because at that level i think there's some opportunity for them to perform some autonomous tasks but um they're also remote controlled because autonomy this is very hard uh and then robot wars which i've been watching which is like i guess entertainment tv and there are some of the systems we talk about like control systems and stuff but there isn't much sophistication in the terms of autonomy although a couple of the teams do talk about things that they've tried to make automatic um but there are also oh what is the name the robot cup is it where oh robocop yeah where robots play like a version of soccer right and they try to do it autonomously
我想他们为初中生和高中生提供了不同等级的比赛，这些是遥控机器人，因为在那个阶段，我认为他们有一些执行自主任务的机会，但它们也是遥控的，因为自主性非常困难。还有我一直在看的“机器人大擂台”（Robot Wars），这大概是娱乐电视节目，里面有一些我们谈到的系统，比如控制系统之类的，但在自主性方面并没有太多的复杂性，尽管有几支队伍确实谈到了他们尝试实现自动化的东西。但还有……哦，叫什么名字来着？机器人世界杯（RoboCup），对吧？机器人玩某种版本的足球，他们尝试自主完成。
for people who don't know the robocop the goal of the robo cup is to have a fully autonomous um robot team that can play the world cup winners in 2050 and uh it's pretty audacious goal um but yeah i mean they have they they tackle like every level of the problem has a competition like there's a competition for who can build the best like humanoid player who can build the best like one foot tall player so on so like there's a whole competition for who can build the best ai and like a pure virtual sandbox uh yeah robo robo cup is amazing and it's an interesting problem which is if the goal is simply to beat the world cup team do you have like you still obviously probably have to obey the world cup rules so you can only have like 11 players but do they have to be shaped like humans i you know i don't i don't know like some of the rules in
对于不知道机器人世界杯的人来说，RoboCup的目标是拥有一支完全自主的机器人团队，能够在2050年击败世界杯冠军。这是一个非常大胆的目标。但确实，他们解决了问题的每一个层面，都有比赛。比如有比赛看谁能制造出最好的类人球员，谁能制造出最好的一英尺高的球员等等。所以，有一整场比赛是关于谁能制造出最好的AI，在一个纯粹的虚拟沙盒中。是的，RoboCup太棒了，这是一个有趣的问题：如果目标仅仅是击败世界杯球队，你显然可能仍然必须遵守世界杯规则，所以你只能有11名球员，但它们必须是人形的吗？我不知道，有些规则在
soccer probably only make sense for humans yeah they're shaped like ankle destroying tiny robots but even if you don't something ridiculous like that like it just might be like very short stout barrels right like maybe that turns out to be particularly optimal but then now like the rules about using your hands or not like don't make a lot of sense i think the implication is to do it with humanoids but it's actually a broader problem for just all of robotics if you're designing a car assembling, it's all about function and very little about form. But if you're building something that's out there with people, you know, form starts to matter a lot more. Yeah, right.
足球比赛中可能只有对人类才有意义。是的，它们被塑造成像会摧毁脚踝的小机器人。但即使你不做那种荒谬的事情，它也可能只是非常矮胖的桶状物，对吧？也许事实证明那是最优的。但现在关于是否使用手的规则，意义就不大了。我认为其含义是使用类人机器人来做，但这实际上是整个机器人技术的一个更广泛的问题。如果你在设计汽车组装，那完全是关于功能，而与形式无关。但如果你要制造某种与人共处的东西，形式就开始变得重要多了。是的，没错。
It's actually like super interesting to read articles and other sources on sort of things which have taken like inspiration from the human form for no reason. The example they gave, which I don't know if I really agree with. They said like the driver in a car sits on one side of the car. And I guess they were arguing it would be better to have the driver sit in the middle. And have two people on either side. Like have the car be a little bit wider. Like I don't know, I i thought this kind of weird but but their whole thing was like oh the a human being is asymmetric on the inside because of your heart and other things right and and symmetric on the outside
阅读关于那些无缘无故从人体形态中汲取灵感的文章和其他来源，其实超级有趣。他们给出的例子，我不知道我是否真的同意。他们说汽车里的司机坐在汽车的一侧。我想他们是在争论，让司机坐在中间，两边各坐一个人会更好。让车身稍微宽一点。我不知道，我觉得这有点奇怪，但他们的整个观点是，人类的内部是不对称的，因为你的心脏和其他器官，而外部是对称的。
what yeah they were trying to draw an analogy between the asymmetry of the inside of a human and the first designs of the car and uh i don't know if okay yeah that seemed pretty out there but but they had a number of other examples too but i think it's kind of interesting and i think over time people learn in the case of something that's purely functional like a robot you know a car building robot or something people eventually get over sort of their own human bias and learn like oh you actually don't need something that has an arm like a human or a human looking hand or but if you're going to have a robot made in your house it needs to open doors and cabinets and obviously those things are meant for human
什么？是的，他们试图在人类内部的不对称性和汽车的最初设计之间建立类比。我不知道这是否……好吧，这看起来确实有点离谱，但他们还有许多其他例子。但我认为这很有趣，而且我认为随着时间的推移，人们会学习。在像机器人这样纯粹功能性的情况下，比如汽车制造机器人之类的，人们最终会克服他们自己的人类偏见，并意识到你其实并不需要一个拥有像人类手臂或看起来像人类手的东西。但如果你要在家里放一个机器人，它需要打开门和橱柜，显然这些东西是为人类
hands to grasp that's true and so then you're kind of forcing the robot to have certain features which even if you don't otherwise intend it needs to be sort of human-like height to be able to reach for instance tall cabinets have sort of human-like grippers so that it can manipulate things designed for humans to open or you're forced to like retrofit everything in your house for like it wouldn't be good for both humans and robots it would be good for either humans or robots unless the robots also look like humans or the humans look like the robots. Yeah. Or maybe like the drawer is like a hybrid where it has a little hole that the robot can,
的手设计的。这是真的，所以你有点强迫机器人拥有某些特征，即使你没有其他意图，它也需要有类似人类的高度，以便能够够到例如高处的橱柜，拥有类似人类的抓取器，以便它能够操作为人类设计的物体。或者你被迫像重新装修房子里的所有东西一样，这对人类和机器人都不好，除非机器人看起来像人类，或者人类看起来像机器人。是的。或者也许抽屉像是一个混合体，它有一个小孔，机器人可以，
you know, like stick something in the hole so that they have leverage. I don't know. But then it's then the adoption problem is hard. Yeah. I do think I'm surprised that by now there aren't self-cleaning toilets where like the toilet has just something in it that just you know like goes around the bowl and like cleans it just seems like it would be something that would break a lot though and really like a toilet is a
你知道，把什么东西插进孔里，这样它们就有杠杆作用。我不知道。但那样的话，采用的问题就很难了。是的。我确实感到惊讶，到现在还没有自动清洁马桶，马桶里有某种东西，你知道，就像在马桶圈里转一圈，然后把它清理干净。但这看起来像是很容易坏的东西，而且马桶实际上是一个
very simple piece of equipment like if you complicate it with adding like a self-cleaning function i don't know i don't know i mean we're off of a software topic yeah i mean i don't know what the control system would be for determining when to clean a toilet yeah i actually do i just don't want to think about it well it's kind of like a roomba where if you clean like the roomba is not the best at the best vacuum like it's not better than a human at vacuuming accurately, but it just runs so many times that eventually it works. Okay. Well, that's all I've got for robotics for now. Cool, yeah.
非常简单的设备。如果你通过增加自动清洁功能来使它复杂化，我不知道。我不知道，我的意思是，我们偏离了软件主题。是的，我的意思是，我不知道确定何时清洁马桶的控制系统会是什么。是的，我其实知道，我只是不想去想它。好吧，这有点像Roomba，如果Roomba清理的话，它并不是最好的吸尘器，它在精确吸尘方面并不比人类好，但它运行的次数太多了，以至于最终它能起作用。好吧，这就是我现在关于机器人技术的所有内容了。酷，是的。
If you've done any cool robotics work, let us know. Post on Facebook. cool robotics work um let us know post on on facebook um facebook seems to be taking over um in terms of number of people um i'm obviously going to keep posting the show on on all of them facebook twitter g plus uh and now linkedin a few people asked me to post on linkedin so i've done that um but uh but yeah if you if you uh if you have a toilet cleaning robot that you want to show everyone post it on Facebook and we can talk about it
如果你做过任何很酷的机器人工作，请告诉我们。发布在Facebook上。很酷的机器人工作……告诉我们，发布在Facebook上。Facebook似乎正在接管，就人数而言。我显然会继续在所有平台上发布节目，Facebook、Twitter、Google Plus，现在还有LinkedIn。一些人要求我在LinkedIn上发布，所以我已经这样做了。但如果……如果你有一个想向大家展示的马桶清洁机器人，发布在Facebook上，我们可以讨论一下。
alright well until next time catch you guys later Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，下次见，回头见。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。